la gastronomie s'installe au centre
eaton de montréal dès jeudi 16 chefs
montréalais de renom seront réunies sous
un même toit
le time to market une première au canada
mais si on après cela nous prend la
démocratisation du haut de gamme
on retrouvera entre autres de brut et du
chef du toqué normand laprise les
restaurants comme le club chasse et
pêche et le montréal plaza auront aussi
un comptoir dans cette ère de 40me quai
car et c'est vraiment ce qu'ils font de
mieux mais on est toutes sélections ils
ont tous une offre environ 2,6 amis
places chacun neymar le concept est
inspiré du magazine time out qui depuis
1968 recommande les meilleures adresses
à découvrir dans les grandes villes de
la planète
le premier time to market à deux jours à
lisbonne au portugal en 2014 sont
ensuite venus new york miami et boston
kanawana chaque chez tous les plats sont
à moins de 20 dollars incluse pour dyson
solennelle du olive et gourmando et du
foxy si tu peux pas permettre de manger
chez fox et le soir mais là tu peur
elle-même
elle s'effectue ce partenariat c'est
aussi de la visibilité comme
l'expliquent pour tous un propriétaire
du agricole ici ça marche et ça sauve en
quoi est-ce que le concept plaira dans
de l'or c'est raisonnable comme budget
je pense que oui oui je suis à notre âge
en plus c'est la conviviale et chic à la
fois selon moi c'est plus santé plus
léger j'aime la variété j'aime les bons
restaurants le time to market a de
bonnes chances de connaître du succès à
montréal la population aime bien manger
selon ce professeur les gens sortent de
plus en plus on s'attend à ce que le
secteur au minimum le times enquête
comporte aussi une offre culturelle
trois bars et une école de cuisine ici
valérie michaela bay radio canada
montréal